tal vez no sea tan obvio que cuando
observas estas tres ecuaciones veas que
son exactamente la misma ecuación la
misma ecuación que solo ha sido
manipulada algebraica mente para obtener
estas tres formas distintas
esta es la ecuación en la forma estándar
de una cuadrática la segunda es la misma
cuadrática pero en su forma factor izada
es decir se ha actualizado esta ecuación
de aquí y la tercera es la misma
cuadrática pero en su forma canónica o
de vértice que es la forma en la que nos
enfocaremos en este vídeo no nos
enfocaremos en cómo llegar de una forma
a la otra
eso lo trabajaremos en futuros vídeos
pero lo que sí haremos es apreciar por
qué se les llama a esta forma la forma
canónica o la forma de verse déjame
escribirlo la forma canónica para
empezar recordemos que es el vértice
bueno puedes recordar de otros vídeos
que significamos una cuadrática y igual
a una expresión en términos de x la
gráfica de esta cuadrática
una parábola ya sea una parábola que
abra hacia abajo o una parábola que abra
hacia arriba esta en particular será una
parábola que abrirá hacia arriba así que
se va a ver más o menos así y para una
parábola que abre hacia arriba
elbert se se encuentra justo aquí lo
puedes pensar como el punto mínimo
tenemos nuestra coordenada x del vértice
y nuestra coordenada y ahora la razón
del por qué se llama la forma canónica o
mejor aún la forma del vértice es que la
cuadrática vista de esta forma nos ayuda
a encontrar las coordenadas del vértice
fácilmente como las encontramos para
hacerlo tenemos que observar la
estructura de esta expresión déjame
escribir las de nuevo para que la
tengamos por acá
james es igual a tres que multiplican a
x + 2 esto al cuadrado menos 27 lo que
es importante recalcar es que esta parte
de la ecuación nunca será
negativa no importa que tengas aquí si
lo eleva al cuadrado no te dará algo
negativo y si esto no va a ser negativo
y lo multiplicamos por un número
positivo entonces todo esto 3 por equis
más 2 al cuadrado no va a ser negativo
es decir será mayor o igual a cero otra
forma de decirlo esta expresión sólo se
sumarán al menos 27 por lo tanto mi
punto mínimo en esta curva de aquí
pasará cuando esta parte sea igual a
cero es decir cuando no le sumemos nada
al menos 27 y cuando es esto igual a
cero bueno será igual a cero cuando x
más 12 igual a 0 por lo tanto si quieres
encontrar la coordenada x del betis se
necesita resolver para que el valor de x
x más 2 es igual a cero y claro podemos
restar dos de ambos lados y obtener x
igual a menos 2 ya sabemos que esta
coordenada de x igual a menos 2 es la
coordenada de nuestro 20 sep ahora cuál
es la coordenada jett del verde
o dicho de otra manera cuál es la mínima
que puede tomar esta curva bueno cuando
x es igual a menos 2
todo esto es 0 y por lo tanto que es
igual a menos 27 así que este de kim es
menos 27 por lo tanto las coordenadas
del vértice serán menos 2 menos 27
observa con esta forma canónica
obtuvimos las coordenadas del vértice de
una manera muy rápida así que hagamos un
par de ejemplos más en donde tengamos la
forma canónica y encontremos el vértice
de una manera sencilla pensemos en el
siguiente escenario donde tenemos una
parábola esta vez abre hacia abajo y que
es igual a menos 2 que multiplica a x
menos 5 esto elevado al cuadrado más 10
aquí tengo una parábola que abre ese
abajo y vamos a ver por qué esta parte
siempre será no negativa y después al
multiplicarse por un número negativo
será no positiva por lo tanto todo esto
será menor
pero para todas x así que sólo le restan
al 10
entonces donde llegamos a un valor
máximo llegaremos a él cuando x menos 5
c igual a cero dicho de otra manera
donde no le quitemos nada al 10
entonces x menos 5 igual a cero esto
pasa cuando x es igual a 5 y esta es la
coordenada del vértice de esta segunda
parábola ahora cuál es la coordenada
gilbert sem bueno cuando x es igual a 5
todo esto es 0 ya no le quitamos nada al
10 y me quedo simplemente con 10 en este
caso el vértice es x igual a 5 y de
igual a 10 que si nos fijamos va a ser
este punto de aquí no estamos usando las
mismas escalas para x y para allá pero
aquí lo tienes y ahora si puedo decir
que mi parábola se verá algo
una parábola que abre hacia abajo
muy bien hagamos un último ejemplo para
sentirnos más confiados en cómo
encontrar el ptc usando la forma
canónica para esto déjame bajar la
pantalla supongamos ahora que mi
ecuación va a ser quien igual a menos pi
que multiplica a x menos 2.8 esto
elevado al cuadrado más 7.1 cuál es el
vértice de la parábola bueno la
coordenada x será la coordenada que haga
esta parte igual a 0 lo cual es 2.8 y si
esto es 0 entonces todo esto será igual
a 0 y james será 7.1 así que estoy
seguro de que ahora puedes apreciar por
qué se le conoce a esta forma como la
forma del vértice ya que es muy fácil
encontrar el vértice cuando escribimos
de esta manera nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo